Miközben hallgattam az előadásodat,
eszembe jutott ez a híres mondás, ez a
gondolat, hogy a nehéz idők erős
embereket termelnek, és az erős emberek
pedig jó időket hoznak. A jó idők
viszont gyenge embereket termelnek ki
magukból. És talán mintogyha ebbe a
ciklusban lennénk most, hogy nagyon jó
volt az elmúlt öt év, az elmúlt 10 év
így az IT piacon. viszont mintha ez az
ellulás, ez az elpuhulás, ez kezdene
érződni, és hogy ezek a poha emberek
most mit fognak hozni, mintogyha ez e ez
lenne az egyik üzenete ennek a
vészcsengőhúzásnak, hogy figyeljetek
ide, mert baj jön biztosan.
Sziasztok! Körülbelül egy éve már van
bennem egy érzés azzal kapcsolatban,
hogy valami közeleg, és valami el fogja
érni ezt az informatikai piacot.
Bizonyos szempontból 2025-ben éreztük,
hogy már lelassul ez a piac, de ezt az
érzést a mai nap abszolút beigazolta,
amikor beszéltem Langmátéval a következő
vendégemmel. Langmáté, ha valaki, akkor
ő rálát arra, hogy mi történik itt az
erdélyi és egyáltalán a globális piacon
is, hogy milyen kvalitások kellenek
manapság ahhoz, hogy egy informatikus
sikeres tudjon lenni. Máté az élete jó
részét, a felét Dubában tölti. a másik
felét Spanyolországban tölti, egy saját
startupot is indított. Erről fogunk
beszélgetni, hogy hogyan látja a
globális piacot, hogy mi is történt így
az elmúlt években itt a romániai
szinten, és hogy körülbelül mi várható
majd a jövőben. Ha érdekel ez a
beszélgetés, akkor tarts velünk. Igen,
hát elérkeztünk a a digitális
székelyföldnek a végéhez, és az az
igazság, én is egy kicsit ki vagyok
fáradva. Nem tudom, hogy te hogy állsz
most még így szaminával.
>> Relatív jól. Köszönöm szépen. Még a míg
a szívem nem robban fel a kávétól, addig
nyomathatjuk.
>> Igen. Hát tudatosan hagytalak téged így
a a végére, mert éreztem, hogy ha most
ezt 40 percbe vagy 20 percbe kéne
belűríteni, túl fontos a téma is. Nagyon
fontos témákról akarok veled
beszélgetni, de mielőtt még belevágunk
ezekbe a témákba, szeretném, hogyha egy
kicsit megismernének így a nézők téged,
röviden összefoglalod, hogy az egyetemet
hol végezted, és utána milyen pozíciókb
dolgoztál az elmúlt időszakban? Persze
nagyon szívesen. Hát ugye én szatmá
németi születéső vagyok. 2010-ben
végeztem a sulit és aztán utána mint
sokan mások kolozsvár felé vettem az
irányt. A Bábesai tudományegyetem magyar
informatika szakára iratkoztam be, ahol
szerintem egy nagyon jó képzést kaptunk
három éven keresztül.
Igazából azt elmondhatom így
retrospektíven, hogy az egyetem az
szerintem a funkcióját az tökéletesen
betöltötte. Ö elég hamar ö kapcsolatba
kerültem az iparral is. Ugye hát ugye
itt a konferencia kapcsán is
elmondhatjuk azt meg akik itt helyben
vannak azok valószínűleg tudják, hogy
ugye Simon Károly tanár úr
elég sok kezdeményezésnek
a az atja mondjuk úgy ilyen ilyen téren.
Tehát ez a
az egyetemnek az iparhoz való közelebb
hozatalához azért ő igen magas mértékben
hozzájárult.
Azt is elmondhatom ugye, hogy annak
idején egy elég válogatott
társasággal dolgozott ő gyakorlatilag
együtt. Tehát még sose felejtettem el a
Bulgakovban volt egy ilyen interjú a a
olyan olyan irányba, hogy
ugye aki vele szeretett volna dolgozni,
az az mindenképpen egy néhány
követelményen, egy követelmi rendszer
néhány pontjának meg kellett felelni.
kötelező volt például RTDK dolgozatot
publikálni, azon kívül kötelező volt
potenciálisan, hogyha tovább tovább
javasolták további terr, akkor
potenciálisan oda is ki kellett venni.
Tehát ezeket a játékszabályokat
a tanár úr az időben időben lefektette,
de hát ez tud tudva a levél volt és
tudtuk, hogy akkor ennek a munkának meg
is lesz az eredménye. Valamint hamar
kapcsolatba kerültünk a Có Spring nevű
céggel, ahol egy egy nagyon kiváló
mentorprogramba vehettünk részt. Ott meg
megint csak itt volt a konferencián a
törökvistai Tamás, aki a mondjuk, hogy a
másik mentorom, tehát a az egyetemi meg
a céges mentoraim közül őket tudnám
erősen kiemelni.
És ezúttal is köszönöm nekik a
hozzájárulást a karrieremhez.
Egy adott pillanatban éreztem egy
kihívást és dobbantottam egyet ettől a
cégtől. Egy nagy céghez kerültem el az
nevű céghez, ahol egy nagy fizetés
feldolgozó platformon dolgoztam. Ott
relatív gyorsan lépkedtem föl a a
corporate ranglétrán és egy adott
pillanatban bejutottam egy ilyen
úgynevezett Software design lead
szerepkörbe, amikor gyakorlatilag egy
csapatnak a technikai kivitelezéséért
feleltem. Tehát többnyire már akkor
ilyen konzultatív architektúra jellegű
szerepkörben dolgoztam. És hát innen
indult igazából az izgalmasabb vagy a
nagyobb váltás, amikor pláne abban a
kontextusban, amikor ez még nem volt
teljesen népszerű, és a startup, mint
fogalom, az még nem nagyon létezett,
pláne nem a kolozsvári piacon.
2016 körül kaptam egy lehetőséget.
Igazából mai napig nem tudom, hogy ki
ajánlott be egy angol befektető
csoportnak a
az egyik oszlopos tagja megkeresett,
hogy neki van egy személyes projektje,
aminek építettek egy prototípust, és
szeretnének egy komoly kolozsvári
csapatot erre a prototípusra
igazából felépíteni, és ugye arra, hogy
ezt a terméket ezt tovább vigyük, erre
sikerült egy 5,5 millió eurós series a
fundingot egy komoly londoni befektető
csoporttól szerezni, és a azon kívül
pedig sikerült egy huszon valahány
személyes technikai csapatot
összeraknunk Kolozsváron, amelyeket én
vezettem. Egyébként ennek a cégnek volt
irodája Londonban, New Yorkban,
Szingaporban és Kolozsváron.
Ekkor kerültem ugye kapcsolatba a
startup világgal és
mondhatom, hogy azóta nem tudtam ezt a
dolgot elengedni. Ez a startup, ez
sajnos nem sikerült nem tudott tovább
menni. Ugye volt már egy csomó előadás
arról, hogy milyen kegyetlen ez a ez a
startup világ, ugye, hogy a az első
körben 60%, a második körben 30
valamennyi morzsolódik le. Mi sajnos
ebbe 30 valamennyi százalék-ba
tartoztunk. a Series Beat nem sikerült.
Voltak ígéretek, voltak jó potenciális
beszélgetések, de aztán sajnos nem
konkretizálódott semmi. És hát kifogy
kifogyott ez a startup a pénzből, amire
személyesen nagyon büszke vagyok, hogy a
termék még fejlesztő nélkül ezután
három-négy
bő évig még működött, és teljes
mértékben kiszolgálta az ügyfeleket.
Nyilván új fejlesztés nem történt rajta,
de karbantartás nélkül autópilóta módon
megtalálta a kiutat.
Úgyhogy erre nagyon nagyon büszke
vagyok.
Azután nyilván miután egyszer az ember
ilyen product cégnél dolgozik, azután
nagyon nehéz visszatérni. Tehát mikor ez
a cég csődbe ment, akkor komoly
problémát jelentett ugye elhelyezkedni a
kolozsvári piacon megint. Ö rengeteg
munkalehetőség volt pedig abb az időben,
tehát elhelyezkedhettem volna, anyagilag
is
teljesen korrekt bérezést
tudtak volna biztosítani, de valahogy
éreztem egy hiányt, hogy ez ez így nekem
nem lesz elég, amíg aztán nagy nehezen
találtam egy egy olyan céget, amelyik
amelyben megtaláltam a helyemet. Ott egy
infrastruktúra csapatot csapatot
vezettem. Az az egy az egy scaleup volt,
egy jóval későbbi stádium matúabb
startup cég végülis, vagy hát ők még
startupnak hívják magukat, de
gyakorlatilag azért ott már más
szabályok
érvényesek.
>> Akkor ők már benne voltak a 99%-ban, ami
meg
>> Igen, ők benne voltak a 99%-ban. Ők egy
nagyon szépet exiteltek, és aztán
eladták egy nagy-nagy amerikai cégnek a
a scaleupot, és egy szép szép exitet
tudhatnak be a tulajdonosok maguk
mögött. Ö ott nyilván teljesen más
problémák vagy máskálájú problémák
voltak. Ott már 100 valahány fejlesztő
volt akinek ugye a munkáját segítette az
én csapatom, ahol a platformot működhető
infrastruktúrát tartottuk mi karban. Ö
ezután dolgoztam még egy, ugyancsak
CTO-ként egy blockchain alapú
befektetési alapnál, ami hát egy idő
után sajnos a blockchain ellen
kedvezőtlen körülmények között meg
valószínűleg a hype utáni
crash miatt az sajnos sajnos bezárásra
került.
És aztán utána belefogtam a Binatch
Agencybe, amikor úgy döntöttem, hogy
lehet megpróbálnám saját magam is ezt a
szoftverfejlesztésnek nevezett játékot
saját szakára vállalkozóként.
Ugye a Binatch
kettő lábon áll, szerintem venture
stúdióként is működünk, ugyanis saját
termékeink is vannak.
Szám szerint kettő. azonkívül pedig a
bevétel nagy rész az még továbbra is
tradicionális úgymond agency
szolgáltatásból, software consulting
szolgáltatásból folyik be. Nagyjából 20
kollégával dolgozunk most együtt
>> jelenleg. Most éppen földrajzilag hol
élsz?
>> Hát ez egy jó kérdés.
Jelenleg földrajzilag Dubaj, Malaga és
Szatmár németi között valahol nemrég
megállított a rendőr egy ilyen közúti
ellenőrzés alkalmával, és elkérte az
irataimat, kérdezte, hogy honnan honnan
vagyok? Hát ugye az autónak román
rendszám volt. Ez Spanyolországban
történt melltam, hogy Romániából akkor
mondta, hogy szeretne egy személytit is
elkérni. Adtam egy magyar személyit. Ez
már fel felvetett néhány kérdést. Utána
elkért a jogosítványomat. Odaadtam a
Dubai jogosítványomat, és megkérdezte,
hogy egyébként mit csinálok itt? És
mondtam, hogy itt élek. Tehát, hogy
nagyjából ezen a komplexitáson tudom ezt
a problémát jobban elmagyarázni.
De gyakorlatilag igyekszem az időmetek
között a három három helység között
elosztani manság.
>> És miért pont Dubá?
>> A Dubában őszintén leges legelőször
főleg érdeklődésből mentünk ki. Ö egy
adott pillanatban meg elkezdtek
megjelenni a a YouTube videóim között
olyan ajánlások, amik
kezdték magyarázni azt, hogy igazából
Dubajban mennyire jó az élet, meg
mennyire jó az ökoszisztém, pláne mint
vállalkozó, mennyire izgalmas
lehetőségek vannak kint, milyen jól van
megszervezve az élet. És ezzel
párhuzamosan elkezdtem azt is látni,
hogy például a LinkedInemen elkezdtek
megjelenni olyan volt vagy aktuális
kollégák, akik
akik odaköltöztek, és kíváncsi lettem
olyan értelemben, hogy akkor vajon
tényleg úgy van-e minden, mint ahogy
ezek a videók bemutatják. Ezzel
párhuzamosan elolvastam a Seik CEO nevű
könyvet is, ami amit a a Dubai Seiknek
az asszisztense, tehát ugye az ottani
vezetőnek az asszisztens írt arról, hogy
milyen
milyen milyen gondolat mentén építik ők
a az országokat. És
elég propagandikusnak hangzott olyan
értelemben, hogy nem hittem el, hogy
azok a dolgok tényleg működhetnek úgy
egy országba, hogy ott ott körbeírják. M
ezért ezért mentem igazából ki én is és
a a feleségem is mindig amikor valahova
így elmentünk akár potenciális
életviteli szándékkal, akkor mindig
igyekeztünk először csak kislábujjal
belemászni a a mélyvízbe. Ö kimentünk
két hónapra, és azt mondtuk, hogyha egy
hónap után még mindig úgy gondoljuk,
hogy ez egy jó ötlet, akkor
továbbléphetünk potenciálisan
keresgélhetünk hosszútávú vagy
középszútávú letelepedési opciókat is,
ami a Dubai esetében a legesleegyszerűbb
egy ilyen investor
letelepedési engedélynek a
megszonzorizálása. Ez egyébként pénzbe
kerül, tehát ezt ki kell fizetni. Ezt a
cég egy megalapított cég után lehet
igényelni. Legalább egy megalapított cég
után az ember többet alapít, akkor csak
egyszer kell kifizetni. Tehát ez egy
>> ez mekkora ez az összeg?
>> Ez nagyjából két évente ilyen most
Euróban ilyen 2500 eur-nyi összeg,
úgyhogy az ügyintézést egy magyar ügyvéd
úriember segítségével jártuk végig.
>> És akkor milyen volt a propagandához
képest Dubá? Mert még mindig ott
vagytok.
>> Igen, meglepően hasonló. Azt kell
mondanom, hogy nyilván költői túlzás
lehet, hogy van a könyvben, de azért
99%-ban
igaznak találtam azokat és pláne azokat
a gondolatokat, ami alapján ezt az
ökoszisztémát ők építették.
Nagyon jó kivitelezés, nagyon jó
szolgáltatások, teljesen digitalizált
állami ökoszisztém. Tehát nagyon
érdekesnek tartom például azt is, hogy
ugye amiről mi most beszélgettünk
kormány digitalizációról, az ott
2012-ben merült felleges legelőször,
amikor mindenki nálunk úgymond
e-governmentről, e e kormányzatról
beszélt, akkor ők már mgvermentről
beszéltek, ami mobil governmentet
jelentett, tehát mobil kormányzást, ami
gyakorlatilag azt jelentette, hogy
bármilyen kormányzati funkció elérhető
kell legyen egy mobiltelefonról. Tehát
ez a jogosítvány igénylésétől kezdve az
adórezidensi igazoláson keresztül
abszolút mindent magába foglal. És ez
így is van egyébként. Szinte minden
kormány
entitássnak, minisztériumnak van egy van
egy saját applikációja, amibe egy
központosított belépési rendszerre
bárhova be lehet lépni, minden mindennel
össze van integrálva. Tehát egy nagyon
kényelmes ökoszisztéma úgy
magánszemélyként, mint cégként.
>> És akkor Spanyolország. Spanyolország az
ezelőtt igazából hamarabb hamarabbi
szerelem volt. A covid után
pár hónappal ugye amikor amikor a
tiltások azok feloldottak, akkor úgy
döntöttünk, hogy egy hosszabbat
kirándulnék. Ugye egy kirándulának ez
egy stresszes néhány év után történt, és
hát teljes véletlenül a Wizardől egy
olyan push notificationt kaptam, hogy
csak ma 9,90 centér lehet utazni a
következő helyszínekre. És megkérdeztem
a akkor a páromat, hogy hova menjünk, és
teljesen véletlenül hallotta ezt egy egy
kolléganőnk, aki azt javasolta, hogy
látogassuk meg őket Malagába. ők
downhill bicikli szerelmesek és rajongók
és Kolozsváron éltek ezelőtt és egy
adott pillanatban, amikor rájöttek arra,
hogy igazából az egész évben ki lehetne
használni a spanyol jó időt arra, hogy
ezt a sportot űzhessék, akkor ők oda
kiköltöztek
és meghívtak magunkhoz minket. Akkor
nyilván ugyanígy turistaként mentünk ki,
tehát körbenéztünk, megtetszett az
életvitel, megtetszett az, hogy azért
ott elég elég nagy a a lazaság, szép a
természet. Tehát ilyen kirándulóhelynek
nagyon-nagyon tökéletesnek éreztük, és
úgy gondoltuk, hogy el tudjuk képzelni
azt, hogy akár potenciálisan többet is
legyünk ott. Úgyhogy következő évben
kutyástól, motorbiciklistől kimentünk
egy eredetileg két hónaposra tervezett
ilyen stakationre, tehát ugye dolgoztunk
is onnan, nem vakáció. Ak kell
elképzelni. Nyilván a hétvégénk, a a
hétvégeink, az esténk azok relaxációs
programmal t teltek el. Tehát
körbemotoroztuk ott az egész úgynevezett
Costa Sol régiót. Ez ugye Malaga
melletti tengerparti régiót Andalúziában
jelenti.
És abban az évben el is döntöttük, hogy
szeretnénk befektetni egy ingatlanba,
láttuk azt, hogy jók a a trendek olyan
értelemben, hogy felértékelődő
és fölfelé mutató íve volt az
ingatlanbefektetéseknek,
valamint rengeteg külföldi ugye pláne a
covid után elkezdte keresni a napsütéses
szép természetet, pláne ugye északi
országokból, Benelux államokból
idősek is, de aztán egyre inkább
fiatalok is, akik ugye Ugye eddig nem
tehették meg, hogy elmennek onnan, ahol
a munkahelyük volt. Miután ugye a remote
munkakultúra az az beütött, azután
rájöttek arra, hogy nem feltétlenül kell
a sötétbe ülni fél évet, és fogták a
sátorfájukat, és odébb mentek a spanyol
tengerpartra.
>> Szuper. Én azt hiszem, hogy ez jól
körvonalazza, habár nagyon sok kérdésem
lenne Dubáljal kapcsolatban is, meg az
életvitelekkel kapcsolatban, de azt
hiszem, hogy ez ez nagyon jól
körvonalazza azt, hogy hogyan éltek. Ö
kicsit térjünk rá magára a startup
világra meg
meg arra a cégre, amit most te vezetsz.
Az első kérdésem az az, hogy külön
kiemelted, hogy van egy outsourcing
része, tehát egy ilyen agency része is.
Ezt fontosnak látod, hogy ez amúgy egy
két lábon álljon a cégetek. Gondolom az
hoz egy stabilitást, és akkor közbe
tudtok kalandozni itt ott a startup
világában. Ezt amúgy tanácsolnád másnak
is, hogy így fogjon neki egy startupnak?
>> Abszolút tanácsolnám.
olyan értelemben ugye, hogy pláne ma
láttuk több előadásban is, hogy azért a
rizikó az megfel az megfelelően nagy
mértékben jelen van a startup
befektetések világába. Tehát ezt
ellensúlyozni mindig jó egy stabilabb
lábbal.
Azt is hozzátenném ugye, hogy ma
felszólaltam amellett, hogy igyekeznünk
kellene a az értékláncba egy magasabb
lépcsőfokra föllépni, amikor a szoftver
agencykről beszélünk és a software
consulting cégek
érték kínálatáról beszélünk.
Igyekszünk olyan olyan kollégákat
fölvenni, akik föl tudják venni a
boxkesztűt komolyabb feladatok ellen is,
akik megértik a cégekben levő politikai
és üzleti kihívásokat
és gyakorlatilag nagy hozzáadott
értékkel tudnak vagy becsatlakozni a
meglévő munkafolyamatokba.
Ezt kevésbé szoktuk preferálni, de van
olyan is, amikor erre van szükség. Tehát
ez az úgynevezett team augmentation
jellegű modell. Vannak olyan kontextusa,
amik akkor ez működik jól, és ezt is
szívesen elvállaljuk, de az igazi
hozzáadott értéket szerintem olyankor
tudjuk produkálni, amikor a labdát az
ügyfél átmeri dobni a mi oldalunkra, és
gyakorlatilag egy nagyobb
felelősségvállalás után
tudunk tudunk közösen értéket teremteni,
és a kontroll is egy kicsit átkerül a mi
oldalunkra. Nyilván üzlet üzleti
folyamat szempontból az náluk van még
továbbra is, mert nyilván ez az ő
bizniszük. viszont a technikai
megvalósítás, a kivitelezés, a support,
a monitorizálás egy rendszernek, az az
többnyire nálunk marad ideális esetben.
Még annyit hozzátennék talán, hogy
másrész pedig nagyon fontosnak tartjuk
azt is, hogy a csapataink azok ilyen
product jellegű próbálkozásainknak
megfelelő módon ki legyenek téve. Tehát
igyekszünk bevonni csapatokat
folyamatosan olyan olyan
próbálkozásokba, akár már ötletfázistól
kezdve, vagy research fázól kezdve olyan
olyan próbálkozásokban, amit
potenciálisan kivitelezésre
készítünk elő. Ezt a kollégák meg is
szokták egyébként köszönni. úgy érzem,
hogy azok, akik nálunk szeretnek
dolgozni, azok ezt ezt folyton
hangoztatják, hogy ezt ezt szeretik, ezt
a részt, hogy a az agyuknak azt a részét
is használjuk, amit talán mindegyik
outsourcing cégnél sikerül
kamatoztassanak.
>> Igen. Hát a am a amiatt is tetszett
nagyon a te elő előadásod, mert nagyon
szépen kiegészít kiegészítettétek egymás
süket Csabával. Ö, a aki nem látta még
azt az epizódot, azt ajánlom, hogy hogy
hallgassa meg ezt az epizódot, és
nagyon-nagyon
tanulságos volt. Ő arról beszélt, hogy
egy melyek azok a rizikók, ami miatt egy
startup becsődölhet. Van ennek elég sok
rizikója, de meglepően kevés maga a a
technológiai oka, hogy nem technológiai
veszélyek leselkednek a startupokra.
viszont a te előadásodban nekem engem
nagyon megérintett az, amit már amúgy is
régóta éreztem. Az elmúlt egy évben
egyfolytában úgy érző éreztem, hogy ez a
vészharang szól bennem. Arról beszéltél,
hogy a világ változik, és fel kell
ébredjen úgy a ez az outsourcing IT piac
itt Romániában, de amúgy szerintem
Magyarországon is, meg itt
Közép-kelet-Európában,
hogy hogy a világ változik, és mi is
változnunk kell vele együtt. És ez az
utolsó utáni vészcsengő. kicsit
kibontanád ezt a gondolatot?
>> Persze, megpróbálom. Hát ugye a Süket
Csaba utáni felszólásom ugye úgy
kezdődött, hogy nem tudtam, hogy
pontosan miről fog beszélni, mikor az
első statisztikák megjelentek, akkor
aggódtam amiatt, hogy ugye az anyám
tyukját kellett ezt 40 percig szavalnom,
mert ugye az én előadásom már készen
volt, és azért érintőlegesen
beszéltünk ugyanarról a témáról, hogy
nagyjából, de hál istennek úgy adta a
sors, hogy nem nem másztunk bele
egymásnak az előadásaiba. Tehát
ő is szerintem egy nagyon jó értéket
tudott egyébként közvetíteni. Tehát az,
amit ő elmondott 30 percbe, az egy White
Combinatoros Startup School-nak a össze
összekomprimált, összenyomt verziója,
amiben minden minden egyes szóérték
volt, és egyébként én is élvezette
hallgattam. Az én előadásom az valóban
egy inkább egy kontextus analízis, egy
ilyen önreflexiós
jelleggel történt. Ugye dolgozunk együtt
külső más cégekkel is. Én pláne
konzultánsként dolgozom együtt olyan
cégekkel, akik elakadnak bizonyos
problémáknak a megoldásában, vagy a
vezetőség az ügyféloldalról úgy
gondolja, hogy nem feltétlen azok az
eredmények
alakulnak ki, amiket amiket ők elvárnak
egy egy másik agencyvel való
munkafolyamat során.
többször előfordult, hogy ilyenkor
fölkértek arra, hogy nézzem át a
folyamatokat, nézzem át a
technológiákat, nézzem át azt, hogy ki
hogy áll hozzá gyakorlatilag a a napi
munkához.
Potenciálisan olyan stresszorok is
lehetnek, amik egy ügyvezetőt egy ilyen
úton elindítanak, hogy mondjuk egy
valamilyen compliance certifikétát,
tehát egy ilyen megfelelési
bizonyítványt meg kell be kell szerezni.
Ez lehet többféle. Ugye itt az Európai
Uniónak sok olyan próbálkozása volt, ami
ami olyan irányba kényszerítette a
cégeket, amire nem voltak feltétlenül
felkészülve, és gyakorlatilag ez a a
tevéken az üzleti tevékenység
befüggesztésével vagy teljes teljes
megállításával is ár, hogyha egy ilyen
megfelelősségi
döntés születik.
Úgyhogy belelátok egy kicsit abba is,
hogy milyen a ezáltal ez az konzultáns
munkám által belelátok abba is, hogy
milyen egy átlagcégnél, mondjuk egy
átlag outsourcing cégnél a a hozzáállása
a kollégáinknak, a a
különböző technológiai, biznisz és
komoly komolyság komolysága, amivel
hozzáállnak gyakorlatilag a a
feladatokhoz, valamint sajnos a
lexikális tudás és a felkész készültség,
tehát egy ilyen több rétű problémát
vélek felfedezni, amit szerintem eddig a
piac nagyon nem tárt fel, vagy nem volt
ennyire evidens, ugyanis
eddig ugye árazásban is Kelet-Európa az
egy az egy relatív kényelmesen,
megfelelően működtethető üzleti modellbe
belefért egy német fizetéshez vagy egy
angol fizetéshez képest, még akkor is,
hogyha tudták ezek a ezek a külföldi
potenciális ügyfeleik az outsourcing
cégeknek, hogy nem pont azt fogják
kapni, amiért egyébként fizetnek. Azért
még mindig megérte, mert hogyha csak
kétharmad arányban volt olyan jó, mint
mondjuk egy német kolléga, és nem
feltétlenül a technikai felkészültségre,
sőt kifejezetten nem a technikai
felkészültségre
tenném most a hangsúlyt, inkább
hozzáállás kérdésére.
még akkor is jobban megérte, ugyanis
1egharmad vagy egy ötöd áron volt. A
probléma az ott van, és azért cs
csengette meg ugye most a vészharangot,
mert úgy látom, hogy ugye az árazásban
igen-igen közel vagyunk a nyugati
piachoz, tehát ugye a belső munkatársak
által támasztott elvárások bérezés
szempontjából, azok már nagyon súrolják
a nyugat-európai határt. Én egyébként
ennek örülök, mert az azt jelenti, hogy
mindenki közben jól él, és ezt szeretném
a saját kollégáinknak, meg magunknak is.
T
>> most hol tartunk a kétharmadnál inkább?
Szerintem még talán több mint a
kéthmadánál is. Nyilván, hogy a nettó,
bruttó közötti országok közötti
különbség az egyébként ezt a
végeredményt, ezt akár befolyásolhatja
ilyen-olyan irányban, de mindenképpen
olyan szinten közelítjük már meg például
egy berlini vagy londoni
szoftvermérnöknek a fizetését, ami
elgondolkodtatja a befektetőket és a az
ottani ügyvezetőket, hogy hogy
szeretnének-e még velünk dolgozni. Még
mindig lehet olyan hozzáadott értékünk,
hogy ügyesebbek, gyorsabbak, jobban
felkészültek vagyunk. Ez szerintem
egyébként a kisebb százaléka azoknak a
kollégáknak, akikkel így a
professzionális karrieren
során találkoztam.
>> Ahhoz, hogy megértsük a mostani
piacunknak a helyzetét, te egy jó pár
dolgot megemlítettél, szeretnék
egyenként végigmenni rajta. Az egyik,
amit megemlítettél, az az, hogy maga az
outsourcing, ez nem egy magas hozzáadott
értékű munka, habár a eleinte a
béreinkhez képest ez egy hatalmas
különbség volt, de valójában a rizikót
még mindig a befektetők vállalják kint
külföldön, és amikor outsörcelnek
hozzánk egy egy feladatot, ez nem magas
hozzáadott értékű. Meg említetted azt
is, hogy a te cégednél is igyekeztek
ilyen product mindsetbe gondolkozni,
tehát hogy ti veszitek át a teljes, vagy
majdnem teljes technológiai
fejlesztést, a termékfejlesztésnek
egy-egy részét, a supportot.
És említetted, hogy ezt látod, hogy ha
nem tud váltani Románia ebben az
irányban, akkor akkor ez egy komoly
okozója lesz annak a lemaradásnak, ami
várhatóan jönni fog.
>> Igen, ez egyértelműen így van. És ennek
az eredményét már látjuk a piacon. Tehát
ugye nagyon sok olyan elbocsátás volt
vagy újraszervezés
címszó alatt történő hosszútávú
lemorzsolása a munkaerőnek, ami ami
egyértelműen arrafelé mutat, hogy azért
itt valamilyen szinten meginog az a
gazdasági egyensúly, ami eddig úgy tűnt,
hogy hogy hosszú távon fenntartható.
Szerintem is mindenképpen az a az a
hosszútávú célunk, hogy ezen az
értékláncon próbáljunk meg föl följebb
és följebb lépni. Ugye a legegyszerűbb
formája annak, hogy kollaboráljunk egy
külső külső céggel, az az, hogy egész
egyszerűen órákat adunk el. Tehát
gyakorlatilag az ügyfél azért fizet,
hogy mi szuszogunk az ő érdekeéiben, és
nyilván valamit valamilyen
artefaktumunkat közben produkálunk.
Ez lehet nagyon hatékony, hogyha nagyon
ügyesek vagyunk. Tehát ugye előfordulhat
az is, hogy egy például egy profi
konzultáns mondjuk nyolc óra
leszámlázásával megold egy komoly biznis
problémát, és ez gyakorlatilag külföldön
sokszor elő is fordul. Tehát
egy németországi vagy angol vagy
amerikai konzultánsakint egy valamilyen
problémának a megoldására felbérelnek, ő
valószínűleg, hogy akár ötször vagy
hatszor is kereshet annyit, mint mondjuk
egy egy itthoni kolléga. viszont az
elvárások is, amit
amit támaszt egy ilyen ügyfél, aki ezt a
pénzt hajlandó kifizetni, az abszolút
eredményorientált. Tehát, hogy elvárja
azt, hogy igen, hogyha most teszem azt
nem tudom, 300-400€-s németországi top
architektnek az órabérét azt kifizeti,
akkor ő két napon belül eredményt akar
látni.
Tehát lehet magas hozzáadott érték felé
felé menni. Viszont ahhoz ott kellene
legyen a tudás, a felkészültség, az
akarás, a az ökoszisztéma.
>> Most mit tanácsolnál egy helyi ilyen
ilyen konzultáns cégnek, aki most ébred
fel és utolsó utáni figyelmeztetésedet
meghallja? Órabéralapon dolgozik ebben a
pillanatban. Mit tud tenni?
El kell mondjam azt is, hogy még
többnyire azért mi is órabéralapon
dolgozunk, mert ez egy folyamat.
Nem feltétlenül az az elsődleges
megoldandó probléma egyébként, hogy az
órabér számlázás az egy mint
keretrendszer, tehát az úgynevez time
and material az létezik. A kérdés mindig
ott van, hogy abból a time and
materiából mennyi az igazi hozzáadott
érték, amit szállítani lehet. Tehát az
első lépés az szerintem az. És egy
egyébként nagyon őszintén bevallva még
azért többnyire mi is itt vagyunk, annak
ellenére, hogy van egy néhány
úgynevezett outcome base, tehát ilyen
eredményorientált
árazású projektünk is, de azért azt el
kell mondanom, hogy mi is többnyire még
time and materiába dolgozunk. Ez még
azért egy bevett bevett szokás.
Viszont, hogyha arra próbálunk
koncentrálni, hogy azalatt az egységnyi
idő alatt mennyi mennyi értéket tudunk
teremteni az ügyfélnek, és egy
transzparens módon próbálunk erről velük
kommunikálni, az szerintem mindenképpen
egy jó első lépés. Kicsit ilyen furcsás
helyzet ez, mert ugye sokszor előfordul
és sokat hallottam azt, hogy hát mi
szeretnénk azt, hogy az ügyféltől több
kompetenciát kaphassunk, hogy nagyobb
legyen a játékterületünk, amin amin mi
gyakorlatilag aktiválhatunk.
A 2010-es évek közepén volt egy ilyen
érdekes helyzet, amikor szerettünk volna
többet, de még nem voltunk azért
teljesen erre felkészülve. De már volt
annyi bizalma a külföldi
ökoszisztémáknak meg ügyfeleknek, hogy
hogy megbízzanak minket bizonyos
feladatokkal. Nyilván egy néhányba
beletört a bicskánk, egy néhányba nem.
Tehát mindenképpen a a gyakorlat teszi a
mester. Tehát ez csak úgy működik,
hogyha megpróbáljuk egyszer átvenni
ezeket a projekteket potenciálisan
technikai nagybácsi nélkül. Én ilyen
technikai nagybácsinak szoktam azokat
hívni, akikhez ugye föl lehet
telefonálni, mondjuk egy anyacékhez, egy
német angol céghez, és amikor úgy tűnik,
hogy kezd a kártyavár összeomlani, akkor
meg lehet őket kérdezni, mégis most itt
mit kellene kezdjünk ezzel a ezzel a
helyzettel. A az emberek edzésen
keresztül tanulják ezt meg, de akkor
nagyon fontos az, hogy a cégek is olyan
környezetet teremtsenek ezeknek a
kollégáknak, ahol ezeket a a mentális
kardokat meg tudják élezni. Másik
oldalról pedig ugye a cégnek a talent
állománya is azért erre kompatibilis
kell, hogy legyen. Ugye beszéltünk a
konferencián sokszor arról, hogy a
junioroknak a helyzete az az most nem
kifejezetten
napos.
Egy nagyon komplex világban, amilyen
most a szoftver világ, sajnos azt kell
mondjam, hogy egy relatív közepesen
fölkészült juniornak nem sok értéke van
egy cégben.
Egyetemen is tanítok
néha betanító tanárként, tehát nem
főállásban. És azt látom, hogy hogy
sajnos nagyon sok mindent kell még
elmondani a diákoknak. Itt az egyetemnek
is valószínűleg, hogy van, amit még
hozzátegyen azért, hogy ez jobb jobb
irányba menjen, de az iparnak is, tehát
itt jobban össze lehetne fonni szerintem
az egyetem és az ipari viszonyt.
Egy juniornak talán akkor lenne esélye
egy ilyen kontextusban, hogyha
nagyon-nagyon mély lexikális tudással
lenne felvértezve. ugyanis azt látom,
hogy ugye az AI asszisztensek
megjelenésével meg ugye egyre egyre
jobbak, tehát olyan ütembe fejlődnek. Én
is azelőtt két évvel egyébként nagyon
szkeptikusan álltam ehhez hozzá, hogy
most már abszolút használhatóak és olyan
gyorságot adnak az embernek, hogy aki
tudja őket jól használni, az akár
szerintem négy-ötz is gyorsabban tud
programozni, mert hogy még lehet mások
nagyobb szorzókról beszélnek. Én egy
kicsit konzervatívabban állok amúgy
ehhez hozzá, de a 4-5szörös szorzó is
hatalmas. Tehát, hogy a négyzörös
szorzónak nyilván bármilyen üzleti
modell az az nagyon tud örülni. Úgyhogy
a juniorok szerintem akkor tudnak
igazából majd érvényesülni, hogyha egy
egy mély lexikális tudással
rendelkeznek, és
relatív sok mindenhez értenek egy
kicsit, és aztán van egy néhány olyan
témakor, amiben aztán elmélyült
tapasztalatot gyűjtenek. Itt a cégeknek
is nyilván, hogy be kell ezt majd ebbe
szállnia.
Tehát említetted azt, hogy volt a
slajodon egy olyan sor, hogy a
csapatokat nem kell megvédeni a vagyis,
hogy túlságosan meg vannak védve ebben a
pillanatban, gondolom a a felelősségtől,
a a technológiai döntésektől, és az
egyik, amire hívnád, az az, hogy
vállaljanak rizikót és felelősséget,
többet a csapatok tudatosan.
Volt egy olyan másik mondatod is, hogy
már nem vagyunk éhes farkasok, inkább
lustamacskákhoz vagyunk hasonlóak. Ezt
kifejtenéd ezt a gondolatot?
>> Igen, hát akkor először a lusta
macskásra próbálok választani. Egyébként
ez nem az én gondoltam, ezt egy
konferencián hallottam valahol
Romániában sajnos nem írtam fel a
notepadembe, hogy konkrétan kitől,
úgyhogy bocsánatot kérek, hogyha
valakitől elloptam. A kód az hiányzott a
a prezentációból, de egyébként nagyon
helyénvalónak érzem.
Tudok egy egy másik olyan
business coachot, aki azt mondta, hogy a
mi generációnkat meg az előttünk valót,
azt a szegénységtől való félelem
motiválta. Mi egy nagyon érdekes
motiváló erő, és valószínűleg, hogy hogy
ez és egyébként ez szerintem is
helyénvaló, és ezt látom a a mi
generációnkban, tehát a mi generációnk,
amikor a munkapiacra került, akkor
szerintem egy olyan mértékű ambícióval
kerültünk oda, meg akartuk váltani a
világot, amit egy kicsit úgy lát,
>> mint az első generációs bevándorlók,
nem? Na, többnyire igen. Tehát szerintem
ez is helyénvaló.
Nem nem volt az opció, hogy mondjuk
valaki ne dolgozzon, vagy hogy egy-két
év után feladjuk, vagy hogy kifáradjunk,
belefáradjunk a munka által okozott ugye
stresszbe. Ez az egyik dolog. A a másik
nem csak feltétlenül a munka a fiatal
munkavállalókra kitérve, hanem nagyobb
kontextusba is. Azért pláne a nagy
cégeknél azt azt elmondhatjuk, hogy
jellemző volt az, hogy nagyon nem
kellett megölnie az embernek magát a
munkával. Tehát úgy bement langyos volt.
Bementünk kilencre, két kávé, egy kis
beszélgetés, tehát már szinte szinte
olyan szintre került el, mint az állami
alkalmazottaknál a munkamorál, hogy itt
kell lenni reggel 9:00-től 5-ig, akkor
hogy tudjuk lecsökkenteni minimumra
azoknak az óráknak a számát, amikor
fárasztó munkával kell foglalkozni.
Ez egyébként nem is volt fair, mert ugye
közben a fizetések azok meg hatalmas
nagyra nőttek. Tehát ugye valaki meg is
említette, hogy mondjuk egy egy
tanárhoz, egy iskolai tanárhoz képest
egy junior programozó valószínűleg
kétszeres szorzót tudott simán elérni
teljesen pályakezdő állapotból.
>> És ezzel együtt egy hálátlanság is, úgy
érzem, hogy feljött bennünk.
>> Abszolút egy hálátlanság is, meg egy
valamilyen szintű arogancia is
szerintem. Tehát ugye a sajnos én is
ebbe a csoportba tartozom, tehát most a
magunk nevében beszélekten én is
fejlesztő vagyok, de hogy azt el kell
mondani, hogy a fejlesztők legalábbis
például Kolozsvári piacon kifejezetten
egy adott pillanatban arrogánsan álltak
hozzá akár munkakereséshez, akár a többi
társadalmi réteghez is. És a motiváció
pedig igencsak eltűnt a háttérből, tehát
elkezdtek eltűnni azok a azok az erők,
amik előrefelé vigyék ezt a bizniszt.
voltak olyan voltak olyan potenciális
ügyfelei cégeknek, akik azt mondták,
hogy van egy projekt, amit kötelező
leszállítani. Volt egy üzleti okból egy
hard deadline, és megnyíltak
gyakorlatilag majdnem végtelen büdzsék
ennek a projektnek az elvárására. És
sajnos Kolozsváron már nem tudtuk nem
tudták azok a cégek az ilyeneket
kivitelezni, mert a kollégák azok jobban
koncentráltak arra, hogy ugye worklife
balance, akkor ők nem szeretnének
hétvégén dolgozni. ö már be van be van
már egy öt
tervezve az elkövetkező három hétben,
akkor azt most nem tudjuk elvállalni.
Nem kell félreérteni. Amúgy nem azt
mondom, hogy folyamatosan az ember rúgja
fel az életét és csak a munkának éljen.
De hogyha és itt a cégek a hibásak, mert
folyamatosan éveken keresztül megvédték,
tehát ez amit kérdezte, megvédték az
embereket attól, hogy hogyan is működik
a mi üzletgunk.
ők nem érezték annak a súlyát, hogy mi
van akkor, hogyha az az ügyfél
legközelebb nem kopog be a miónkon,
hanem egy olyan helyre fogja elvinni,
ahol megoldják neki a problémáját, és
még potenciálisan lehet, hogy kevesebb
pénzből is oldják meg a problémáját.
Ugye ez amit nagyon veszélyesnek tartok,
hogy és ezért is én igyekszem bármikor,
amikor valamilyen üzleti lehetőségünk
van, akkor igyekszem a a kollégánknak
elmagyarázni a kontextust, elmagyarázni,
hogy ki az ügyfél, mekkora az
opportunity,
potenciálisan miért szeretnénk azt, hogy
esetek túlórázzanak. Igyekszünk olyankor
mi is több szupportot adni, és
igyekszünk hálásak is lenni utána
azoknak, akik ezen az úton velünk végig
akarnak menni.
Visszatérnék egy picit talán arra, hogy
kérdezted az elején, hogy mi az, amit
ami Dubában megtetszett, vagy ami amit
úgy éreztem, hogy talán különböző az
európai ökoszisztémához képest.
Dubajba szerintem, hogyha lemész egy
véletlenszerű vasárnap egy coworking
space-be,
akkor azt látod, hogy nagyjából 50%-baan
tele van. Ez egy nagyon érdekes dolog,
ugye egy olyan Európából jöv, ahol a
vasárnap az ilyen teljesen munka
munkaelkerülős nap. Tehát nincsen azzal
se semmi gond. Viszont a Dubai
ökoszisztémában még azt látom, hogy a
délutánok is potenciálisan valamilyen
hassleel, side hasustsellel telhetnek
el, vagy ha nem mással, akkor
orvasással. egy nagyon-nagyon produktív
környezet, és mindenki, aki odakerül, az
val vagy úgy látom, hogy igazából erre a
kaptafára van gyártva. Ezt sok sokan fel
is hozzák, hogy hát Dubajban mindenki
munka munkamániás, vagy hogy mindenki
folyton előre törekvő. Mindenki
eldöntheti nyilván, hogy ez jó vagy
rossz. Ön picit hiányolom Európából azt,
hogy hogy ez a ez a fajta kultúra talán
teljesen eltűnt, vagy nem nagyon nem
nagyon találom nyomát a a pláne a
nyugat-európai, de most már az a baj,
hogy nálunk sem. És azért mi nem
rendelkezünk mondjuk egy norvég
befektető alap háttérrel, amikor ugye
minden állampolgárnak valamilyen szinten
biztosítva van a jóléte. Nekünk azért
még sokat kellene pedálozni
középkelet-Európában, mert le vagyunk
már amúgy is maradva 50 évvel. Igen. Hát
miközben hallgattam az előadásodat,
eszembe jutott ez a ez a híres mondás,
ez a gondolat, hogy a nehéz idők erős
embereket
termelnek, és az erős emberek pedig jó
időket hoznak. A jó idők viszont gyenge
embereket termelnek ki magukból. És
talán mintogyha ebbe a ciklusban lennénk
most, hogy nagyon jó volt az elmúlt öt
év, az elmúlt 10 év így az IT piacon.
viszont mintha ez az ellulás, ez az
elpuhulás, ez ez kezdene érződni, és
hogy ezek a puha emberek most mit fognak
hozni, mintogyha ez ez lenne az egyik
üzenete ennek a vészcsengőhúzásnak, hogy
figyeljetek ide, mert baj jön biztosan.
>> Abszolút ezzel egyetértek. Ugye az a
baj, amikor és ezt például ugye Robert
Kioszakinak is a könyvében olvashatjuk,
én nem vagyok egyébként az alkalmazotti
státusz ellen egy kicsit sem. Meg a ugye
céget vezetek, tehát mi a kollégáinkra
igyekszünk
odafigyelni, vigyázni, és nincsen azzal
semmi baj, nem kell mindenkinek
vállalkozni, rengeteg áldozatot követel.
viszont például azt az eszmét, amit ő
ott leír, hogy van az a szint az
életvitelben az embernek, amikor már nem
él rosszul, de már de még lehetne annál
sokkal többet is tenni a jóléte, vagy a
továbbhaladása érdekében. Ez lehet
karrier vagy életszínvonal
szempontjából, viszont egy olyan langyos
zónába érkezik be, amikor már nincsen
akkora nagy stresszor hátulról, amiért
érdemes lenne. Tehát a motiváció picit
eltűnik, és akkor ott valaki úgy érzi,
hogy ezen a szinten, ezen a szinten
szeretne megállni.
Azt is tudni kell mindenkinek amúgy,
hogy mi az, ami elég. Tehát, hogy ugye
anyagi szempontból az elképzelhető, hogy
ez ez így elég. Csak ugye ez a mi
szakmánk, ez egy folyamatosan fejlődő
szakma, és nem biztos, hogy mindig olyan
kontextus van, amikor az a például az a
projekt, vagy az az ügyfél, akivel
dolgozol, az a top technológiákkal,
legújabb módszertannal tud
tud veled dolgozni. olyankor szerintem a
te feladatod kellene legyen az, hogy
hogy nagyon tudatosan figyelj arra, hogy
karrier karriervédelmi
üzemmódba kapcsolj. Nyilván mi is
igyekszünk a a kollégáinknak segíteni,
tehát például minden évben elmegyünk
piacvezető konferenciákra, ahol külföldi
előadók adnak elő
nagy cégektől, tehát olyan nagy
cégektől, ahol igazából a mi mi
szakmánkat magas fokon űzik.
Nagyon sok olyan ismerősöm, barátom van,
aki azt mondja, hát ő ilyesmre nem
küldt. Hát küldje el a cég, hogyha
szeretné, hogy ő holnap jobb legyen,
akkor elvárja, hogy akkor a adjanak neki
szabadnapot, fizessék ki a konferenciát,
még lehetőleg akkor valami pluszt is
előtte utána, hogy tudja kipihenni az út
fáradalmait. Na ez most megváltozott.
Tehát itt most már egyértelmű az üzenet,
hogy itt mindenki magára kell elsősorban
vigyázzon. Vannak olyan cégek, akik
amúgy vigyáznak rád. Tehát mi azért
igyekszünk valahol a kettő között
pozicionálódni. Amúgy a mi kollégáink
értékelik is. Tehát volt egy céges
felmérésünk, ahol egyértelműen kimondták
azt, hogy például ez az oldal a a mi
cégünkben való
létnek, ez ez nekik kifejezetten
imponáló, és az, hogy a kollégák is egy
olyan magas technikai színvonalon
vannak, amivel amivel ők úgy érzik, hogy
ez egy olyan környezet, amibe amibe
holnap holnap után így szívesen
bejönnek, és nem marad senki sem hátra.
Nálunk is van olyan projekt, olyan
technológia, ami nem feltétlenül az ú a
legutolsó
három-négy évbe pattant ki valakinek a
fejéből, de hát azokat az ügyfeleket is
ki kell szolgálni. Viszont azt akkor
próbáljuk ellensúlyozni talán olyan
tanítási meg
exposure részen, ahol ahol olyan
dolgokról tanulhatnak, vagy olyan
dolgokat próbálunk
nekik földobni, olyan labdákat, amiket
hogyha leütnek, azzal mindenki jól jár.
Téged amúgy mi motivál? Mi az, ami ami
ami húz előre ennyire szenvedélyesen?
>> Ez egy nagyon jó kérdés, és igazából
ugye ma önreflexióról beszéltem,
szerintem erről sokat lehet beszélni.
Az egyik dolog az nyilván a siker. Tehát
szeretném szeretném azt, hogy
elmondhassam, ugye már pár startupba
mondtam, hogy beletört igazából a a
bicskám, olyan értelemben nem
feltétlenül veszem teljes mértékbe a a
felelősséget az csak az én vállamra,
hogy azért ez egy sok komponensű dolog.
Tehát láttuk a Csaba előadásából is,
hogy azért egy startupat nagyon sok
mindenen elbukhat.
Azt se mondom, hogy amúgy mi nem
hibáztunk, de szeretném azt, hogy egy
olyan közösséget építsünk a a Bin
hatchen belül, ahol ahol mindenki
egyformán jól jár, ahol olyan
technológiákat tudunk használni olyan
problémáknak a megoldására, ami igazából
tényleg értékes, olyan ügyfeleknek, akik
jól láthatóak, akik bizniszkritikus
dolgokat oldak meg. Tehát nekem mindig
az volt a a kedvenc
projektem, amelyiken ugye a
legvizibilisebb volt, a legláthatóbb
volt az, hogyha valamit sikerült
javítani. Tehát a valami olyat olyat
építesz, amit amúgy a potenciálisan
milliók használnak, akkor az azért
mindig ad egy ilyen
egy ilyen kielégülést a az embernek.
Tehát abszolút
talán ez a ez az építői kultúra meg ez
az építői ö elégtétel az, ami amire azt
mondanám, hogy hogy előre visz. És
azonkívül pedig nyilván azok az emberek,
akiket akiket jó környezetben tudunk
ezáltal tartani, és akiknek a szürke
állományát ilyen dolgokra tudjuk
használni, és olyan környezetet tudunk
nekik teremteni, ahol ők jól érzik
magukat.
A az AI most ahogy bejött, ezt
mindenkitől megkérdezem, és nagyon
kíváncsi vagyok a véleményedre, ahogy
ahogy egyre inkább látom, hogy bejön és
egyre nagyobb teret veszel most már a
fejlesztőktől is, kódot generál és
és dokumentációt generál és és
gyakorlatilag anélkül már fejleszteni
szinte elképzelhetetlen.
Hogy látod, hogy kié lesz a jövő? Milyen
kvalitásai kell legyenek annak a
személynek, aki most kezdi? Tegyük fel
az egyetemet, mit tanuljon, hogyan
tanuljon, és ki lesz a jövő, ki lesz az,
aki sikeres lesz.
>> Ühüm.
Hát elsősorban én talán inkább a szenior
kollégákkal kezdeném, mert ugye ott is
szerintem lesz egy elég komoly
transzformáció olyan irányba, hogy az AI
azokat, akik eddig is nagyon jók voltak,
azt azt nagyon nagy mértékben fel fogja
gyorsítani. pont azok a skillek, amik
ahhoz kellettek, hogy egy egy termékből
igazán jó, skálázható, biztonságos,
gyors és egyéb ilyen nonfunkcionális
jelzőkkel illetett terméket tudjunk
teremteni, azok most nagyon
nagyon-nagyon felszínre törnek. Ugyanis
például, hogyha az AI-jal való
programozásról beszélünk, akkor nagyon
pontosan el kell tudjuk mondani azt,
hogy mit várunk el. Most, hogyha ezt
cizelláton is jól meg tudjuk fogalmazni,
akkor valószínűleg az eredmény is az
nagyjából jó jó minőségű lesz. Nyilván,
hogy utána pedig azt is folyamatos
iterációkon keresztül ki kell tudni
értékelni. Meg kell mondani, hogy mi az,
amit talán nem gondolt jól, mi az, ami
abban a kontextusban vagy üzleti
helyzetben
nem jó fit, és azokat meg kell kérjük,
hogy akkor írja ő át, vagy hogyha én
őszintén harmadik- negyedik
próbálkozásnál nem sikerül elérjem, amit
akarok, akkor azt mondom, jó, akkor ezt
most megírom én, de a többi
többi helyzetben igyekszem az AI-t
használni. Tehát azt mondanám, hogy pont
arra a sokrétű tudásra van szükség, amit
és ez lesz talán a junioroknál nehéz,
amit amit az edzés során lehetett
igazából el elsajátítani.
Ez a tudás ez
annak a feloldására is
irányul, ugye, hogy az informatikában
szát az armos előadást, aki látta, az az
valószínűleg legalább akkorát lépett
hátra, mint én. Ugy már nem tudom a 10.
15 virtualizációs színnél tartunk. Tehát
ugye ott van a hardware, azon ott van a
egy hypervisor, az am van egy operációs
rendszer, aminek a tetején van egy nem
tudom, egy konténer. A konténerbe fut
egy alkalmazás, az alkalmazásba behúzunk
egy libraryt, tehát hogy itt már annyi
minden van, amit át kell látni, akkor az
ugye kommunikál egy
egy hálózaton keresztül valakivel, annak
a hálózatnak van egy protokollja. Tehát
ezekbe a dolgokba már annyi hiba
csúszhat be, vagy annyi specifikum van,
amik
amik a működést befolyásolják, hogy
ezeket, hogyha valaki át akarja látni,
akkor egy picit ezekhez a elméletinek
tartott fogalmakhoz azért hozzá kell
tudni szólni, meg hozzá kell tudni
nyúlni. Ezekbe az absztrakciós cselekbe
látom például az igazi szenoritásnak a
nagyon nagy hozzáadott értékét. Tehát
például egy incidensnek a megoldásában
valaki, aki ilyenekkel gyakran
találkozik, az exponenciálisabban,
gyorsabban meg tudja oldani a problémát,
mint mondjuk egy unió. Egész egyszerűen
azért, mert nekünk volt rá időnk, hogy
ezeket egyenként megtapasztaljuk, és az
az igazság, hogy ennél jó kevésbé
komplex környezetekbe.
Az én személyes véleményem az az, hogyha
egy junior be akar törni erre a
munkaerőpiac, akkor elsősorban
szenvedésen kell szeresse az
informatikát, mert nem lesz egy egyszerű
menet. Tehát amikor mi informatikusnak
mentünk annak idején,
nagyon-nagyon jó képzést kaptunk megint
akkor felhoznám és ezúton is megköszönöm
Demeter Csaba és Bálin Zsuzsa
tanáraimnak a azt, hogy idáig
eljuttattak.
Nagyon jó képzést kaptunk ilyen
értelemben, és mindenki, aki a kezük
alól kikerült, az azért ment informatika
egyetemre, mert szerette ezt a szakmát.
Tehát azt kell mondjam, hogy ha jól
tudom, akkor az osztálytársaim közül
mindenki a szakmába dolgozik, aki ezt az
egyetemi utat követte. Utána sajnos ugye
sajnos és szerencsére mivel ilyen jól
ment az informatikusoknak, és erről is
beszéltem, ezért nagyon sok olyan ember
is odament, aki egyébként valami más
szeret szenvedélyesen csinálni, viszont
ezt jól megfizették.
Az ő belső motivációjuk egy adott
pillanatban nyilván lemorzsolódik. Tehát
bekerültek egy munkakörnyezetbe, az
abszolút kötelezőt, azt ők tudták
teljesíteni, nem rúgták ki őket, nem is
olyan volt a kontextus, hogy bárkinek
üzet érdeke legyen az, hogy egy egy
kollégát azt eltávolítson egy fizetőt
fizetett székről.
Viszont elveszed elvesztődött egy picit
talán a ez a ez a az elit oldal az
informatikának. Na most azok az emberek,
akik továbbra is az informatika
szenvedélyes szereteté miatt kerülnek
ebbe a szakmába, azok valószínűleg az
egyetemi éveik alatt is, meg a céges
éveik alatt is
olyan tudásra fognak megpróbálni
szertenni, ami ami ami ezeket a
témaköröket például, mint az előbb
elmondtam, azért mélyen érinti. onnantól
kezdve a következő lépés nyilván a céges
kultúrának a megtanulása, az ügyfélrel
való kommunikációnak a a megtanulása és
egyéb ilyen
biznis jellegű feladatköröknek az
elsajátítása, meg a egész egyszerűen az
üzleti életben való részvétel, meg a
mindennapoknak a a a challengeinek a a
megoldása, ami alatt rengeteget fejlődik
egy kolléga.
Szóval én igazából erre erre fektetném a
hangsúlyt, hogyha ha egy dolgot
mondhatnék, hogy a az a lexikális tudása
meg az a
az a pragmatikusság és kritikus
gondolkodás, amivel egy informatikus ma
fel kell legyen vértezve, az az abszolút
esszenciális. Ezenkívül, bocsánat, nem
még ennyi, hogy ezen kívül szerintem azt
senki sem tudja megjósolni most ebben a
pillanatban, hogy merrefelé fog az ipar
elmozdulni.
Ezt ez csak egy ilyen közép középtávú,
maximum középtávú ajánlás lehet, és ez
megváltozhat úgy, hogy mindenki magának
döntse el, hogyha jó ötlet ebbe
belemászni, vagy nem. Nekem más
lehetőség, nem hiszem, hogy lett volna.
Én pici gyerekkorom óta tudtam, hogy
amikor első számítógépre rátettem a
kezem, tudtam, hogy engem ez fog
érdekelni, és szerencsére a szüleim is
ilyen irányba tereltek, és maximálisan
támogattak, hogy ebbe az irányba
mozduljak el.
Tehát, hogyha egy junior, bocsánat, egy
egy érettségiző diák
érzi magába ezt az elhívást, hogy az IT
az, ami vonza, akkor számítson arra,
hogy nehéz harc lesz, de csak akkor
fogja tudni ezt a nehéz harcot
végigvinni, hogyha tényleg szereti, mert
ha nem, akkor a a bicskája bele fog
törni. Csak a nagy fizetés önmagába,
egyrészt nem is garantált, másrészt
pedig
nem fogja a nagy fizetés önmagában nem
motivál hosszútávon eléggé. Én én nagyon
sok embert láttam, akik kiégtek
egyszerűen, és ez az AI, ez csak
gyakorlatilag felgyorsítja a kiégést,
mert többet várnak el rövidebb idő
alatt. Szóval meg kell kapni azt, hogy
ez tényleg ez az út, amin el akar
indulni, vagy pedig nem. És hogyha
elindult, akkor amit megtanultam most
tőled, az az, hogy igazi product
mindsettel gondolkozzon, vállaljon
felelősséget, holisztikusan értse meg,
hogy mi az mi az értelme annak, amit
csinál. És és a a úgy, ahogy mondtad, a
az értékhierarchiában minél magasabbra
tegye ezt a a létszet, minél nagyobb
hozzáadott értéke legyen, és próbáljon
meg a befektetőnek a fejével
gondolkozni.
Amit még észrevettem nálad, hogy hogy
nagyon-nagyon mély ismereted van.
Egyrészt a szakszavakat nagyon jól
ismered, de a befektetői szakszavakat
nagyon jól ismered. Amúgy ezeket hol
tanultad meg? Hogyha most így az elmúlt
10 évet nézed, mi volt az a ilyen
workshopokon tanultad, vagy az
internetről olvastad, vagy ennek az
egyelege, vagy beszélgettél emberekkel,
vagy mentorod volt, vagy h hogy hogyan
lehet ezt felszedni ezt a tudást?
>> Talán, hogyha egy egy rossz pontja van a
legalábbis a romániai iskolai meg
egyetemi oktatásnak, akkor az az, hogy
ez egyáltalán nem nincsen érintve
semmilyen tantár keretén belül,
semmilyen oktatás, semmilyen workshop,
semmilyen extra kururikuláris
tevékenység alatt. Nyilván vannak olyan
dolgok, amik segítenek a ahhoz, hogy
hogy valamilyen szinten simul simulj
hozzá. Tehát azért vannak ilyen
ötletbörze jellegű mint tudom én
diákversenyek vagy ilyen biznis
jellegű ötlet
késő ilyen biznisplani dolgozó versenyek
amik segítenek, de például klasszikusan
azért az informatikusok ezt nem keresik.
Én személyesen őszintén, amikor
bekerültem az első startupomba, és egy
olyan környezetbe kerültem, ahol
folyamatosan olyan terminusokat
használtak a a környezetemben, amit amit
nem ismertem, akkor nyilván elkezdtem
olvasni. Ez nagyon kevés volt. Tehát
ezáltal nem lettem okosabb. Nyilván,
hogy akkor már megértettük egymást, de
hogy a startup világban egyébként ez
nagyon jellen van, ez a a lingónak a
használata. Tehát rengeteg rövidítés
van, rengeteg olyan dolog, ami a
kultúrának a része, ami vagy a
szubkultúrának a része, hogyha
hogyha így szeretnénk megfogalmazni. És
nyilván, hogy a az a kitettség, ami amit
az okoz, hogy például egy CEO-val vagy
egy chief product officer, egy CPO-val
el kell menni mondjuk egy nagy corporate
ügyféllrel beszélgetni, akkor az ember
beletanul abba, hogy mi az, hogy
termset, hogy mi az, hogy PNL sheet,
hogy tehát, hogy ezekbe ezekbe a
dolgokba nyilván beletanulunk, meg mi
az, hogy go to marketplan, vagy mi az,
hogy product roadmap. Tehát ezek a
dolgok, amiket sajnos tényleg az
egyetemen nem nagyon tanítanak, és
szerintem kellene
beletanul azokba a dinamikákba, és
amiken keresztül megy egy start. Tehát
tehát mi a mi az, hogy board meinting,
mikor mikor kaphatunk befektetést, mikor
jó valamit fölhozni, mikor jó egy
productot lancsolni, mikor érdemes
luncsolni, hogy kommunikáljunk róla.
Tehát mivel a CTO szerepkörben voltam,
azért gyakorlatilag minden más
funkciójával a cégnek
kollaborációba kerültem. Tehát
akár marketing, akár hájáró oldalon,
tehát egy ilyen elég sok rétű munkám
volt nyilván a csapatnak a technikai
vezetése mellett. És hát
utána pedig amikor már ez a ez a
folyamat elindul, és amikor
beleszerettem a a startup világba, akkor
elkezdtem tényleg fölkészülni. Tehát
például van egy csomó nagyon jó is
egyébként ingyenesen elérhető anyag. Y
combinator például az egy nagy amerikai,
talán világon a leghíresebb startup
inkubátor, akinek van egy Startup School
nevű programja. Mindenkinek nagyon
ajánlom, még akkor is, hogyha nem
informatikus, tehát ilyen bármilyen
biznis doménban használható tudást lehet
szerintem ott szerezni, ahol nagyon
szépen elmagyarázzák a
termékfejlesztőnek a buktatóit, a rossz
kommunikációnak a buktatóit,
a nem megfelelő pénzkezelésnek a
buktatóit egy cég életében. Tehát ilyen
szempontból mindig azt mondom, hogy én
programozó vagyok, ezt ma is elmondtam,
a többi azt nagyjából rámragadt. Tehát
vagy nehéz tanulások és drága tanulások
árán, amikor ugye a saját elkövetett
hibákból kellett ezeket megtanulni.
Hogyha pedig nem, akkor azért elég sokat
olvastam utána ennek a témakörnek,
előadásokat néztem, startup
konferenciákra jártam. Ami talán jó, az
az, hogy ez egy elég befogadó közösség,
tehát hogy pont talán pont azért, amit
Csaba is elmondott ma az előadásában,
hogy ugye nagyon sokan ebbe bele
belebuknak, és
ez egy ilyen elfogadott dolog, tehát
szoktak rendezni még szándékosan ilyen
úgynevezett fuckup nightsokat is, amikor
konkrétan arról van szó, hogy ki hol
rontotta el a bizniszét, a startupetát
potenciálisan az életét megtörő vagy
mellékvágányra juttató dolgokról
beszélni. Ezek az emberek relatív
nyíltan, és egy olyan felszabadultság
érzést ad nekik az, hogy ezt másokkal is
megoszthatják, és tudjuk azt, hogy
igazából nem csak mi vagyunk néha nem az
éremnek a rossz oldalán, hanem más is.
>> Záró kérdésként azt kérdezném tőled,
hogy ha most visszamehetnél az időbe, és
beszélhetnél egy öt percet Langmátéval,
aki 10 évvel ezelőtti éned, mit üzennél
neki?
>> Fú, hát ez egy nagyon érdekes kérdés.
Talán azt üzenném neki, hogy legyen
empatikusabb. Például olyan értelemben,
hogy pláne egy technikai felkészültségű
ember, mint amilyen én is vagyok, amikor
például egy ügyfél problémát kell
megoldani, ami lehet, nem egy ideális
technikai megoldáshoz vezet, akkor
alapvetően egy ilyen undorral nyúl nyúl
hozzá ehhez a ehhez a problémakörhöz.
Tehát ilyen megerőszakolt szerepkörből
próbál valamit valamit varázsolni,
és talán megpróbálnék simulékonyabban
hozzá hozzáállni, és kevésbé fafejűen
hozzáállni a bizonyos bizonyos kliensek,
ügyfelek által, plá a
termékfejlesztésről beszélünk,
támasztott igények igények felé. Ez ez
talán segített volna az első startatba
például olyan értelemben, hogy ne
ne tartsanak például a fejlesztések
olyan sokáig, ameddig potenciálisan
tartottak. Annak ellenére ugye, hogy a
minőség az ott volt a háta mögött, de
lehet, hogy
az öt évvel ezelőtt énemnek
elmagyaráznám azt, hogy vannak olyan
rövidítések, amiket érdemesnél
megcsinálni. Talán még akkor is, hogyha
minőség kárára megy, talán akkor is,
hogyha egy suboptimális vagy nem ideális
helyzetet eredményez rövidtávon, mert az
életbemaradásnak az pedig lehet a az
áloga.
Máté, köszönöm szépen az időt. Nagyon
értékes volt és sok sikert neked a a
startupodhoz. Remélem, hogyha egy pár év
múlva leülünk beszélgetni, akkor azt a
sikert, amit te most így nagyjából
körbeírtál, azt el is fogod tudni írni.
Akkor viszont nagyon kíváncsi leszek,
hogy mit látsz sikernek majd abban a
pillanatban.
>> Nagyon szépen köszönöm és gratulálok a
kezdeményedzést a podcasthoz. Köszönöm
szépen. Az utóbbi időben nagyon sokat
foglalkoztat a startupok világa, nagyon
sokat foglalkoztat az oktatást téma, és
a következő pár epizódomat erre
szeretném szentelni, meghívni a legjobb
vendégeket, akik meg tudnak szólalni
ezekben a témákban. Ha szeretnél
támogatni ebbe a munkába abban, hogy
ezeket a témákat minél inkább ki tudjam
bontani, és a mögöttük rejlő alapelveket
meg tudjam érteni, és ezt podcast
formájában veletek is megosszam, azzal
tudtok támogatni, ha feliratkoztok erre
a csatornára. Azt vettem észre, hogy
körülbelül 80%-a a nézőknek nincs
feliratkozva a csatornára. Gyertek és
iratkozzatok fel. Ez nagyban segít és
motivál engem is, hogy tovább folytassam
ezt a kutatást, és ezeket az érdekes
témákat hozzátok is elhozzam.